as Donald Trump signs yet another trade
deal and reveals a Middle East peace
plan amid an economic boom it raises a
key question how can a president do so
many effective things and still face a
hateful opposition if you ask people to
grade his work based on their lives
they'll tell you things are great cuz
the results are obvious more jobs higher
wages peace prosperity but if you ask
them about impeachment or about the
president in general their responses
will vary so why is that well maybe they
know what happens if you say anything
nice about Trump or it could also be
Trump's personality if you rubbed you
the wrong way four years ago maybe he
still does but also the media runs the
turf where facts and opinions can be
moulded into any narrative they desire
we know the golden oldies
Trump's unstable he's about to cause
World War three he's a racist he's not
responsible for this economy all or a
matter of opinion born from emotion
disconnected from concrete results and
yet like a t-shirt cannon the media can
shoot those messages to you at home that
call it an honest day's work it's safe
to say much of the disconnect between
Trump's results and the polls are
largely media driven the media is like
the bitter ex-spouse whispering bad
things to the kids about the other
parent and impeachment is their way to
really tart a guy and they aren't even
hiding it the upside to all this it
seems impeachment really revs up an
already competitive president you try to
bring him down and he just does more if
you keep at this he'll probably cure the
corona virus and make China pay for it I
I hope so why'd that monologue was
dedicated to you it was like dedicating
a song I think you would agree on that
with the trade deals the peace plans the
dead terrorist
impeachment has made Trump the most
effective president in our lifetimes
really first on the coronavirus I have
had the sniffles Lee yes it agreat it's
been a great concern to Dana because
I've been sitting I know so I was
thinking if he can really solve the
corona virus Greg may have now maybe I
don't want him to I put eyedrops in your
coffee anyway in response I would say
this you could say the
yep I think the US MCA isn't a good
thing right like especially for our
farmers our trade deals that's good
stuff I would say if he really had a
Mideast peace plan I would say marvelous
boy that would solve so many problems
but that doesn't negate that what he did
with presidents olicity and the Ukraine
is bad I mean it's like saying yeah I'm
a good person but I robbed somebody that
doesn't work yeah you can't say to the
judge hey Katie Katie's a wonderful
partner but you know she just beats
someone in the head and therefore forget
analogies need to fix well no because
what we have heard today in fact was
this argument about abuse of power and
you heard it quite another most amazing
part of today by the way Alan Dershowitz
saying oh you know what it doesn't if
the President believes that his
re-election is in the national interest
then it doesn't matter you can't you
can't impeach a man well I think he's a
king anything anything no that's
actually true if you believe you're an
effective president but the other thing
too they don't abuse of power it's not
criteria because it's new very Dana it's
vague you could say that about any
policy you don't like yes absolutely
they cut land for any time remember when
President Obama said I don't need you
Congress I've got a pen and a phone yeah
it was like you can't do that you have
to go through the democratic process but
nobody impeached him over it no I'm not
we tried I think that the Patrick
Philbin yes lawyer for the president's
team he's really effective I think as
just explaining things to people and
when he's he emphasized you have not
proven these things beyond a reasonable
doubt so anybody who served on a jury or
watched one on TV that is the standard
beyond a reasonable doubt and they
haven't done that and I also think that
with the news today that Cory Gardner of
Colorado the senator there has said he
is a no on witnesses I think it's safe
to say that by Friday Mitch McConnell
will have the votes there will be no
witnesses the president will be
acquitted mmm yeah I consider myself a
legal expert from my years of watching
law and order so I have to back you up
on this Jesse you know we're all going
to the Super Bowl so I thought
go with a Super Bowl analogy or a
football analogy you know with this new
trade deal and the peace deal isn't
Donald Trump like Earl Campbell
you know he's can cross the goal line
tearing people in remember Earl Campbell
used to everything like he was a big
back and he'd run in the oil it's like
what people would jump on him he would
just move forward and score is it
doesn't Trump more effective when he has
such resistance that's right and we're
the offensive linemen okay
helping them plow the field right one
balance now the entire media okay relax
I was telling the truth over here all
right here's what I see what's going on
right now the hatred all right
Trump is beating the Democrats at their
own game usually you can tell a
Republican and say you know you're only
good for Wall Street and you're not good
for Main Street but for the first time
in a long time this president has been
good for both and this has been a
bottom-up recovery and not only that for
the working men and women wages are up
but also for blacks and Hispanics so
that makes the Democrats furious that
he's doing what they've been promising
to do for three decades and haven't been
able to do and a businessman comes in
and does it in three years so there's an
all-out assault on him the second thing
is he goes on offense constantly either
it's on Twitter if it's on the press
conferences we're not used to having a
president just bludgeon the opposition
so forcefully and so aggressively on all
spectrums 24 hours a day it's unsettling
to a lot of people and people just
aren't used to it and then third I just
think the speaking style is jarring for
a lot of people he's from Queens he's
brash he's blunt he gets right to the
point and it's very politically
incorrect so it's an Irving to hear the
president United States go directly at
people like that and just shake things
down to the core so at the end of the
day you've made this analogy and I'll
double down on it although it's not an
Earl Campbell analogy if you have a
platoon leader right you don't like him
but you respect him and he keeps killing
the enemy or you have a CEO who's
driving you crazy keeps you at work
till 9 p.m. but the earnings are
fantastic and you got a great bonus or
what about a football coach mmm he's
Yellin at you all the time he's making
you run wind sprints but you just won
the Superbowl you don't have to love the
guy to respect him because winning is
most important you know Katie you
usually get your facts straight
yeah yes Dana Dana brought up the fact
that it's probably won't be any
witnesses is that a good thing well I
think it depends I mean if you can be
open to new witnesses who were not part
of the House process but the problem is
that the house is sending over a case
that doesn't have everything done so the
Senate you can the question is if you're
a senator how could you vote against
witnesses at this point knowing what you
know about John Bolton in the book and
the answer is because the Senate doesn't
want to have a precedent set where the
house can just send over any kind of
impeachment process without doing all of
the work and as the attorney argued
today for the White House that would
enable the Senate to become an
investigatory body it would then force
them to be an impeachment forever as the
house sends over partisan impeachment
and it's important to point out that
there are two sets of witnesses here the
house interviewed 17 people those
people's testimony has been used in the
Senate trial on both sides to prove a
point there was nobody in the Clinton
trial who testified in the house and
then testified in the Senate who wasn't
interviewed before the articles of
impeachment in the entire House case was
sent to the Senate and so that's I think
senators looking at him saying we're not
the house and you need to do your job
and you know the rebuttal came from the
Democrats who said they've been 15
impeachment and witnesses in all them
including in one case I think this was
the Johnson case like 37 of the 40s to
fight in the house but testified in the
Senate so it's not like this is
unprecedented it is unprecedented all
right